hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem kleinen tutorial ich aufnehme ich
habe ja schon mal ein video dazu gemacht
allerdings ist dieses video schon ca
sechs bis sieben monate alt und da hat
sich ein klein wenig verändert und ich
bekommen halt immer wieder fragen wie
geht das und ja das ist nicht mehr
aktuell das video und so muss denn
beantworten deswegen mache ich jetzt
einfach mal ein aktuelles für euch ich
möchte mich entschuldigen dafür dass
sich allgemein meine stimme ein bisschen
schlecht ist es ist gerade 13 uhr ich
bin gerade aufgestanden und da kann man
nicht so viel davon erwarten also das
tut mir leid aber achtet einfach auf das
was ich hier mache und ihr habt nach
eine ganz gute videoqualität und
audioqualität wenn ihr das wirklich
genauso macht bzw gut ist immer relativ
also werden eure videos halt auch so
aussehen wie meine
also ich fange jetzt mal an ich habe
einen rohde nt 1a ich habe ein behringer
mischpult also das braucht man halt ist
das audio interface ich habe einen imac
und ich habe einen zweiten bildschirm
das ist der syncmaster es a350 so dass
erst mal zur hardware die man dafür
benötigt tastatur und maus ist ganz egal
kann jeder das dem wasser will die
einzigen programme die ich wirklich so
zum aufnehmen benutzer sind minecraft
halt hier so und audi city auch dass
dies das programm mit man seine stimme
aufnehmen kann und zwar haben viele das
problem wenn sie autos ich muss übrigens
auch das city nehmen weil das rodeln t1
ist ein mono mikrofon deswegen steht
hier auch mono und fraps ist das einzige
programm also fraps kann nur stereo
aufnehmen wartet das sieht man wo sieht
man das so sieht man das stereo raps
kann nur stereo aufnahmen ohne mikrofone
deswegen muss ich meine stimme immer mit
oder city aufnehmen aber das ist für
mich auch eigentlich ganz gut weil viele
haben das problem wenn sie bei rastet
die aufnehmen und dann auch bei mit
fraps ihr das hier also nimmt mit autos
die eure stimme auf und mit fraps das
bild von einem fenster also meinem falle
minecraft und den ton von den pc dann
ist das oft asynchron wenn man die erste
stadt muss und dann da aber da kommen
wir gleich zum 2 das einen kleinen trick
dem eigentlich glaube ich gar keine
verwendet jetzt eigentlich ganz gut in
den verrate ich euch einfach mal also
einfach noch kurz dran bleiben kommen
wir erst mal zu fressen gibt es von
general button der ist aber ganz egal da
können einstellen was ihr wollt das sind
nur so sachen wie ich
und so das möchte ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt zeigen fps ist eigentlich auch
relativ egal ich will hier einfach nur
fps ankreuzen und dann hier oben rechts
ihr könnt es natürlich auch hierbei
machen
ihr seht das verändert sich ja dann ist
es da unten aber oben rechts ist einfach
am besten weil hier unten ist oft zu
inventar oben links steht auf die
version von minecraft und oben rechts
steht einfach gar nichts also das ist
ganz gut
movies das ist das wichtigste ich wird
immer den desktop auswählen wo das
gespeichert wird also change dann kann
man hier einfach desktop video capture
krotki das ist ganz wichtig dass wir
hier den gleichen nehmen wir ihn auch
dass wir die gewählt habt ich habe hier
zum beispiel f9 ich könnte mal euch das
hier in europa sind die zeigen wo ist
das genau das ebtida war das aufnahme
debatte das war irgendwo hat die
softkeys da geht einfach auf tastatur
kommt schon irgendwo unten was da
aufnahme f9 das heißt wenn ich nachher
ein auto city f9 drücken im fraps
automatisch genau zur gleichen zeit auch
mit aufhängt an aufzunehmen das heißt es
ist genau synchron
das kann ich euch gleich zeigen und zwar
machen erstmal bei fraps weiter hier
müsst ihr 29 97 eingeben das ist nämlich
genau die rate die bei youtube verwendet
wird ihr könnt auch 30 eingeben
aber das ist eigentlich ganz egal ich
hab halt 29 97 hier macht einfach rekord
windows 7 sound stereo und wenn ihr ein
stereomikrofon habt dann könnt ihr das
natürlich hier auswählen allerdings ist
meins halt das ist halt mein mikrofon
der eingang hier der zirkus allerdings
ist mein zelt mono deswegen lasse ich
das immer also macht es einfach nicht
screenshots könnt ihr auch einstellen
was ihr wollt mache ich immer jpeg
eigentlich und f10 habe ich als für
frettchen eigenen ordner wegen
screenshots aber egal das ist das
allerwichtigste es macht einfach auf 9
und bei oder city auf 9 und hier nur
einen eigenen sound dann habt da stand
dann könnt ihr fraps minimieren und
jetzt habt ihr auch das city oder city
kann ich mal ganz kurz zeigen hier den
eindruck wird eure spur aufgenommen
hier lastet einfach alles so wie es ist
hier ist es wichtig dass er am mikrofon
auswählt ich hab noch das g35 womit ich
höre allerdings wäre ich einfach mein
eingangs mikrofon aus hier ist es auch
wichtig dass im mono eingibt und dann
mache ich es eigentlich mal so ich habe
ein zweiter bildschirm das heißt ich
kann auch das ist die einfach so
hierüber ziehen
allerdings lasse ich das jetzt einfach
mal hier um euch das zu zeigen ich nehme
jetzt mal ganz kurz für euch aufgehen
mal kurz in
el tri wasteland survival so da sind wir
hier ist die welt das müsste jetzt ein
bisschen haken weil ich gerade mit band
die cam ein bildschirm und mit fraps
sitzt ja auch noch aufnehmen
aber es egal jedenfalls mache ich jetzt
immer pause in minecraft kv das sieht
die drücke f9 jetzt achtet man auf die
fps hier
wenn ich drücke die fps werden direkt
rot und hier nehme ich gerade meine
stimme mit oder city auf also dann
klicke ich auf minecraft hier stelle
mich irgendwohin macht 518 nochmal fünf
dann kann ich mich zu drehen sagte hallo
meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge heute
der segways land wollten wir uns ja um
die monster falle kümmern und so weiter
dann nehme ich halt so eine stunde auf
und dann wenn ich fertig bin drücke ich
in dem bildschirm hier escape drücke
wieder f9 gehen mit der maus rüber und
drücke space das ist das ende ist
natürlich nicht synchron aber der anfang
und das möchte ich euch jetzt mal ganz
kurz zeigen ihr könnt jetzt noch ihre
stimme abspulen neuen drücke die fps
werden direkt rot und hier nämlich grad
meine stimme mit einer city auf also
dann klicke ich auf minecraft hier also
ihr hört da schon hier in owl city mache
ich gar keine bearbeitung ich klicke
einfach auf datei exportieren desktop
dann zum beispiel wasteland folge 144
bisschen falsch
klickt einfach auf ok dann exportiert ja
das ganz kurz dann habt ihr das dann
könnt ihr das schließen
minecraft können wir ausschließen so und
fraps können wir jetzt auch schließen
das brauchen wir alles nicht mehr
das einfach nicht wundern dass ist die
datei die ich jetzt gerade auf nehme
aber das ist egal so was ich da noch
machen ist und das machen ganz wenige
das macht noch skate skate macht das
noch ich glaub krank macht das noch
rahmen schnitzel ist eine
nachbearbeitung der audiospur mit der
doppischen ich werde euch nicht zeigen
wie das funktioniert skate hat mir das
erklärt und meinte dass man bitte nicht
so raus und ich möchte auch ehrlich
gesagt ich rausgehen weil jeder kann
dort seine eigenen einstellungen treffen
und das city ist ein programm das die
adobe audition ich mache alles mit adobe
ich mache die fans mit photoshop die
bearbeitung mit premiere und 3d sachen
mit after effects und tonbearbeitung mit
oder augenoptischen mein gott komisch
eine so ihr habt hier audition das
fenster kann ja ganz erklären könnte
hier einziehen dann habt ihr das hier
wählt ihr alles ausland hier oben ganz
viele effekte anwenden könnt allerdings
muss das jeder für sich anwenden wenn
ihr dann fertig seid einfach auf datei
exportieren datei und dann könnt ihr
hier auch exportieren so also das war
ein bisschen aber das lasse ich jetzt
erstmal weiß erstmal gar nicht so
wichtig für euch youtuber also das macht
eigentlich keinen großen unterschied
dann kommt das wichtigste und zwar
premiere wird bildet übrigens ich habe
die ganzen sachen hier alle kostenlos
über die schule bekommt so und nun das
allerwichtigste wo ich immer wieder
nachrichten bekommen ab ich krieg das
sich hin
also klickt auf neues projekt so das
könnt ihr mal ganz kurz hier so angucken
so habe ich das alles eingestellt ich
glaube aber sind sogar die standard
sachen ich nenne das jetzt mal einfach
weg komm lass das könnte eigentlich auf
umbenannt lassen dass es ganz egal
und zwar spreche ich das immer in dem
ordner dann lasse ich das immer
überschreiben
hier wählt ihr hdv aus und da 1080p und
30 frames so die ganze sache nämlich
jetzt wasteland test aufnahme so ok und
nun sind wir in premiere
hier habt ihr ein fenster wo ihr sehen
könnt was sie unten reinzieht wir das
halt aussieht hier habt ihr eure ganzen
dateien hier habt ihr effekt
einstellungen für einzelne clips und bei
den options das benutze ich eigentlich
nicht so ihr nehmt eure beiden dateien
also die bearbeitet eigentlich habe ich
ja da noch eine bearbeitete audiospur
die nehme ich dann und diese datei aber
nun nämlich einfach die beiden ziele dar
ein letzter drin
sodann habe ich hier so einen ordner der
heißt con 2.0 da sind intros drin da ist
hier die musik drin und wichtige sachen
wie dingens dateien aber es egal habe
ich eine twitter datei eine facebook
datei die erste anmerkung und das intro
die ziehe ich jetzt da rein
dann habe ich von coaching nirvana hier
ein paar lieder dann nehme ich jetzt
einfach mal 1 sich auch noch daran
also und das ich sag ja immer
nachweisbar nachbearbeitung ist das
wichtigste oder seht ihr auch schon ich
habe zwei dateien aufnahme und fünf
dateien alleine der nachbearbeitung und
das werde ich jetzt mal ganz kurz zu
machen und zwar ziehe ich das jetzt da
rein und da ich minecraft im
fenstermodus spiele ist das ganze hier
ein wenig klein sage ich mal
microsoft im fenstermodus könnt ihr
spielen indem ihr einfach den minecraft
seiser oder den magic lounge oft
verwendet da mache ich auch frame größe
skalieren dann habt ihr und nicht die
blöden streifen so das kann uns jetzt
mal ganz kurz angucken so ihr hört jetzt
wahrscheinlich keinen sound vielleicht
wer ganz genau hingehört hat den stein
klopfen gehört das egal
also das ist unser clip das ist so quasi
das video und dann eben einfach die
audiospur ziehen niederrhein die ist am
anfang da mache ich hier immer auf den
pfeil dann sehe ich dass die ist am
anfang hier immer ganz normal also
wirklich komplett synchron neuen drücke
die fps werden direkt rot wohin kann es
dann ganz kurz hier machen
acht noch mal fünf dann kann ich mich so
dreht sagt so hallo hier meine lieben
freund und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge oft mache ich dann einfach
nur quatschen schneidig dass drei moment
richtig zu drehen so hat so dann mache
ich einfach hier zack zack
so könnte das hier ein bisschen da sieht
man ja schon anfang alle meine lieben
freund und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge heute in der asset based
nennt wollten wir uns ja um die monster
falle kümmern und so weiter so und da
das jetzt ein gutes ende war schneidig
dass er einfach genau bis dahin und die
audiospur von mir auch genau bis dahin
so jetzt haben natürlich ein säcklein
clip eigentlich wenn ich das machen
würde wäre der klub dann zu 45 minuten
lang so wie ich immer aufnehmen
dann packe ich da noch musik hinter so
ist jetzt natürlich blöd weil das stop
mit einem lied eigentlich versuche das
immer so zu machen so lieder auswählen
dass die nicht mitten im lied stoppen
und jetzt hört ist natürlich schon die
stimme übertönt also das lied übertönt
ich habe heute am ende direkt auf dafür
nehmen wir eine konstante leistung ich
habe hier schon benutzt